on a oublié ta petite présentation les
salamalecs d'usagé et ont te présente
comme grand sorcier de l'internet option
vie privée mais en fait tu es qui tu
fais quoi et tu as fait quoi tu comptes
faire quoi je suis qui je suis benjamin
bayart ma bio twitter dit vieux condé
internet parce que j'ai pas trouvé mieux
activiste militant dans plein de merdier
associatif au tour du net depuis une
vingtaine d'années j'ai été longtemps
président de french data network qui est
le plus vieux fournisseur d'accès
internet de france et qui est une
association loi 1901
je suis actuellement président co
président avec orianne pierre-louis de
la fédération des fournisseurs d'accès
internet associatif je suis également
membre co fondateur de la quadrature du
net
président du fonds de défense de la
neutralité du net
typographe amateurs à mes heures
un des exégètes amateurs pour les gens
qui connaissent pas les exégètes
amateurs c'est un groupe de juristes et
d'informaticiens moi je fais
informaticien dans la bande
qui se chargent d'attaquer tout un tas
de décret de loi
liberticide soit en matière de vie
privée soit en matière de libertés
numériques
soient enfin surtout ce genre de sujets
là ça fait deux ans et des poussières
contourne on a déjà obtenu quelques très
jolies victoires tu vois quand comment
l'avenir avec tout ce qu'on sait on va
pas on rentrait dans tout le détail du
flicage sur internet tu veux rentrer
dedans pendant qu'il va rentrer dans le
détail pour le moment l'avenir moi je le
vois très sombre mais pas par une
analyse politique autour d'internet par
une analyse plus plus macro
ccd des trucs bébêtes si tu veut cesser
de la la politique à deux sous
la montée de la misère fait toujours une
montée de l'extrême droite toujours
c'est le cas pendant la crise de 29 et
puis ça se termine pas très bien dans
les années 30
c'est le cas en ce moment c'est le cas à
chaque fois que tu as une montée de la
misère et que tu as des formes assez
extrêmes de misère qui se développe
ça crée des tensions et des angoisses
dans la société ça fait monter l'extrême
droite parce que ça fait monter la haine
de l'autre
en ce moment en france
tu as des formes de misère à ces
extrêmes qui sont développés assez forte
des gens qui arrivent pas à s'en sortir
géré ce qu'on appelle les travailleurs
pauvres par exemple c'est un vrai
problème des gens qui ont un boulot coin
salaires et qui dorment dans leur
voiture ça c'est un problème
travailleurs pauvres ou esclaves bas les
esclaves il dormait dans un lit figure
toi il dormait pas dans leur bagnole
donc c'est certes ils sont pas esclaves
ils ont le droit d'aller voter pour
choisir un président qui n'ont pas le
choix mais ils dorment dans leur bagnole
ils dorment pas dans un lit ils n'ont
même pas dans un dortoir donc c'est
esclaves c'est pas le bon mot tu vois il
ya une forme de respect chez celle
esclavagiste on retrouve pas chez
l'employeur moderne
et à l'heure actuelle rien ne laisse
penser que le gouvernement va traiter le
problème de misère galopante donc rien
ne laisse penser que l'extrême droite va
reculer et
si tu veux le pen est tellement aux
élections que je vois pas comment
comment ça va finir au moment du très
mal kouassi ont pris une petite boule
quand même députation et non mais
toujours puisque toute façon le mode de
scrutin fonds qu'ils aient fait qu'ils
n'ont aucune chance vers les lecteurs
front national il n'est pas tellement
plus con qu'un autre il sait que ça sert
à rien de lever le cul de sa chaise il
reste assis chez lui
il sait qu'aux présidentielles il a une
chance une chance d'obtenir que le ps au
second tour alors il va voter puis quand
elle est au second tour il va voter il
sait qu'il passera pas il n'est pas
content il sait qu'elle passera pas mais
il va voter
pour lui pour les députés il sait que ça
sert à rien faut pas prendre les
électeurs pour des idiots c'est ses
traits d'abord c'est très insultant puis
c'est en moyenne pas vrai ils savent
très bien ce qu'ils font
ainsi votre mac rond il sait ce qu'il
fait
d'une certaine façon oui consciente ou
non
en général le public qui vote macron
c'est le public dominance et le public
pour qui la société actuelle convient
sont des gens qui sont plutôt éduquer
plutôt blanc plutôt riche j'entends par
rich pas forcément milliardaire 500
euros par mois c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils
ont un boulot et pour qui ça va
raisonnablement bien si tu veux ils ont
pas très peur d'être au chômage il se
demande pas comment on va faire pour
nourrir les gamins ils ont pas renoncé à
acheter de la viande parce qu'ils en
avaient pas les moyens il continue à se
chauffer l'hiver tu vois c'est pas c'est
pas arich
avec des salaires de pdg c'est juste
c'est des gens pour qui ça va bien en
fait et si tu regardes ce sont les
dominants de la société actuelle c'est
des gens qui sont plutôt cadre start-up
heures
qui vont absolument aucune crainte du
chômage compas l'idée de ce que c'est
que de passer deux ans en bouleau est
d'arriver en fin de droits
c'est les 8 millions de stars topper de
macron c'est ça ils sont pas tous start
eu peur mais c'est oui
c'est les c'est en fait c'est la france
qui va bien qu'ils votent macron c'est
la france pour qui la société actuelle
est correct quoique si tu veux elle
marche
elle apporte les bonnes réponses là ils
sont en train de discuter l'arrière
boutique sur des histoires de micros
du coup moi je suis trop déconcentré
oui t'es pas content c'est ça c'est
vraiment ouvert parti tu lorsque tu vas
prendre
non mais moi je me déconcentre il faut
bien qu'ils expliquent ma carrière mais
ce qu'il te vois pas faire le messie en
live c'est notre prime time
doit pas se prendre au sérieux on se
retrouve sans une bon
tu me couper voilà bon revenons donc
l'électorat macron je ne sais pas s'il
est conscient du fait
je sais pas s'il est conscient du fait
qu'il est la puissance dominante et
opprimante de la société actuelle mais
il l'est et ils votent selon ses
intérêts de caste
l'intérêt de caste de tous ces gens là
c'est que la société change pas puisque
c'est un modèle qui certes détruit plein
de gens mais qui leur permet de vivre
bien
ils en sont contents parce que tu penses
que quand la crise va arriver dans l'est
dans les assiettes ou comme disait
ma grand-mère quand les uns quand il
n'ya plus de foin dans les râteliers les
chevaux se bat est ce que quand cette
masse qui a réussi à prendre le pouvoir
de à peu près de 8 millions d'électeurs
va commencer à voir la crise arriver
dans leur assiette qui vont arrêter de
réfléchir en mode macro non non non en
fait ils vont arrêter de réfléchir en
mode macro fur et à mesure qu'ils vont
tomber dans la misère dire que c'est pas
les tranches hautes de cet électorat
c'est l'étrange basse
toutes les petites gens pour qui ça va à
peu près bien qu'ils votent macron parce
que ces modérés que quand même on va pas
voter le pen parce que c'est du fascisme
et tout ça du donjon
bah les petites gens pas contents ils
votent mélenchon oui puis ils ont plutôt
raison
parce que ça correspond aux problèmes
aux questions qu'ils posent quoi même si
la réponse de mélenchon elles sont pas
fabuleuse
les questions posées sont les bonnes le
le cancan le bas de l'électorat macro se
retrouvera dans la misère ils vont
basculer alors ils vont basculer ou bien
côté mélenchon ou bien côté le pen mais
beaucoup côté le pen je pense tu vois
c'est beaucoup même temps
j'en sais rien ça dépendra de la
politique menée par le gouvernement
actuel mais je crois que l'idée est
globalement plutôt de faire dans
l'ultralibéralisme et dans la réduction
des droits et des protections des
salariés
ça ça fait monter la misère ça la fait
pas baisser verger pas j'ai pas lu dans
le programme du gouvernement actuel
l'idée de faire un traitement social de
la misère l'idée de faire en sorte
qu'ils aient plus de miséreux en france
point on en a les moyens vers la france
est assez riche pour que personne meurt
de faim et pour que personne n'ait
d'angoise ni en matière de logement ni
en matière d'alimentation ni en matière
d'éducation ni en matière de santé on a
les moyens financièrement de ça alors il
tue elle la répartition des richesses
fait que ça n'a pas lieu mais même avec
le demi de 2200 milliards de dette oui
oui même avec nos de 1200 milliards de
dette
la dette vient essentiellement de
l'intérêt de la dette hier que la dette
ne vient pas du déficit à vient du fait
qu'on paye des taux d'intérêt parce
qu'on emprunte sur les marchés quand
quand les gens de gauche disent qu'on
cesse d'emprunter sur les marchés et
qu'on emprunte à la banque centrale
européenne au même taux que la bnp quand
elle se refinancent juste au même taux
que la bnp c'est à dire à peu près peau
de balle et tout d'un coup le service de
la dette diminue c'est 30 40 milliards
d'euros par an les intérêts de la dette
c'est de cet ordre là je me goure pas
ça ça fait un [__] de trous 40
milliards d'euros tous les ans juste
d'intérêt sur la dette qu'on paye pour
rien il n'y a aucune raison puisque le
garant en dernier ressort c'est toujours
la banque centrale européenne donc que
la banque centrale européenne se porte
garante de la dette de la france où que
ça se fasse via des investisseurs à qui
ont emprunté qu'ils devront se
refinancer à la banque centrale
européenne c'est toujours le même jeu
simplement entre temps on a nourri des
intermédiaires inutiles
qui sont un sérieux
tout le système financier derrière les
gens auprès de qui on emprunte et qu'ils
vont refinancer leur dette parce que
l'air de rien quand ils doivent
emprunter auprès de la banque centrale
il faut qu'ils viennent avec des titres
solides qu'ils apportent en garantie et
c'est quoi les titres solides qu'ils
apportent en garantie c'est de la dette
d'état française c'est de la dette
d'état allemandes donc en fait la france
emprunte à taux d'intérêt n'ont nulle à
des banquiers des compagnies de banques
et assureurs des investisseurs ce genre
de personnes là qui eux devront se
refinancer auprès de la banque centrale
européenne en empruntant à taux nul et
en apportant comme garantie les titres
de dette française
agir t'enlève l'intermédiaire inutile et
la france va juste déposé ces titres de
dettes auprès de la banque centrale et
obtenir de l'argent en échange et ça
fera bien pareil tous conçus pain
parce que les traités internationaux
nous l'interdisent
haute en a quelques-uns dans l'est
dans les accords européens dans les
traités fondateurs de la banque centrale
européenne typiquement la banque
centrale européenne n'avait pas le droit
de faire du ce qu'on appelle du
quantitative easing sur le fait
d'émettre de la monnaie et ils se sont
mis à le faire et à le faire en très
grande masse après la crise de 2008 pour
sauver le système bancaire mais ils le
font toujours en passant par
l'intermédiaire des banques cercueil la
banque centrale émet de la monnaie
qu'elle prête aux banques qui s'en
servent pour prêter à d'autres avec un
facteur multiplicateur à chaque fois
mais ça pourrait se faire en prêtant
directement à l'état c'est ce que fait
la réserve fédérale américaine juste
nous nous le sommes interdits revenons à
nos moutons
le terrorisme et internet quand on
entend les politiques dire que les gens
se radicalise sur internet ça fait qu'on
s'a coin bah c'est parfaitement vrai
c'est parfaitement vrai les gens se
radicalise sur internet les jambes
drague sur internet aussi les jambes
aise sur internet les gens font tout sur
internet donc en fait les gens qui se
radicalise il se radicalise dans le
monde dans lequel ils vivent au 19ème
siècle il se radicalise et au bistrot au
xxème siècle qui se radicalisait dans
des manifs il se radicalise et à la télé
il se radicalise et en écoutant les
discours des politiques et en disant que
c'était des mensonges
maintenant il se radicalise sur internet
mais tout se fait sur internet donc en
fait ça c'est une non déclaration il
quand on objecte que qu'internet ça va
plus vite ouais ça touche plus de monde
oui ça va plus vite sa touche plus de
monde c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair
moi je vois plus si tu veux le travail
des services
de police pour faire simple de ces
trente dernières années
il ya eu un travail très fort pour
détruire toute la sphère d'influencé de
l'extrême gauche lors qu'on s'entende
quand je parle d'extrême gauche je parle
pas de mélenchon et son orchestre
je parle de la vraie extrême gauche avec
elle la vraie
celle d'action directe celle des
brigades rouges
l'extrême gauche très dur dans tiffin
d'antifascistes
typiquement les petits bouts qui en
reste c'est les antifas même si ceux là
sont relativement soft
c'est de l'extrême gauche pas violent
que les antifas
en fait l'intérêt qu'avait l'extrême
gauche comme structure sociale cette
extrême gauche là
c'est qu'elle récupèrerait les exaltés
et qu'elle les politiser les éduquer
s'en faisait pas des gentilles sens et
pas des tendres mais simplement quand
ces gens-là décidé de passer à l'acte de
manière violente il le faisait de
manière très réfléchie et ce qui faisait
le plus gros comme attentats s'étaient
de séquestrer un pdg de l'exécuter pense
au pdg de renault par exemple
il visait pas la foule ils n'essayaient
pas de faire dérailler les trains tuer
des gens et de tirer dans la foule dans
un concert tu vois c'est absolument pas
la forme que ça prenait ça prenait la
forme d'un attentat politique d'un
attentat disant ok l'ennemi c'est le
grand capital donc on va abattre le
grand capital on séquestre le pdg de
renault on l'exécuté terrain c'est pas
forcément bien je dis pas que c'est bien
de faire ça je dis que c'était une façon
finalement pas si bête de récupérer
toute une génération d'exalter
et de les amener à faire de la politique
au lieu de faire juste de la violence et
comme tout ce milieu d'extrême gauche
n'existe plus et n'est plus capable
d'absorber les exaltés
qui les récupèrent les djihadistes et
eux ils cherchent pas aller politisé il
cherche pas à les instruire il cherche
pas à leur expliquer marx comme un tome
2 tomes 3 non ils cherchent juste à les
faire passer à l'acte vite et à les
faire mourir en passant à l'acte donc
les ceintures d'explosifs les
kalachnikov ont tiré dans la foule tu te
feras abattre par la police et humour à
en martyr et c'est pas du tout
je trouve pas que ce soit mieux si tu
veux
le modèle où on en faisait des militants
extrémistes très dur et qui en général
finissait en prison
ils n'étaient pas forcément plus malsain
mais ça fait une trentaine ou une
quarantaine d'années que tous les
services de police en europe ont peur
des attentats d'extrême gauche vers les
actions directes en france et les
brigades rouges en allemagne ça a laissé
des souvenirs et des souvenirs très dur
et donc il ya il ya un contrôle assez
fort et qui continue de toutes les
mouvances extrême de tout les mêmes les
mouvances anarchistes portant n'y a pas
eu d'attentât anarchistes en france
depuis plus de 100 ans
il reste un contrôle policier très très
très très fort là dessus
parce que il ya une peur la peur de
l'état de perdre ses pouvoirs régaliens
je sais pas parce que je crois pas que
ces mouvances là puisse faire 51% à
quelque élection que ce soit
en revanche c'est c'est effectivement
les sources anciennes d'anciennes forme
de terrorisme et il reste des réflexes
dans la grande maison police
de crainte de ces milieux là après il se
trouve qu'effectivement
typiquement les milieux anarchistes
pour ce que j'en ai lu
développe une pensée politique un peu
plus structuré que celle du parti
socialiste
tu me diras c'est pas très dur
s'ils me veulent les mots de la bouche
mon ami bon si on discutait on se
découvre un petit peu pour revenir après
sur ce sujet là on va parler crypto
monnaie
qu'est ce t'en pense on passa les terres
après le pic quand on fait du bit
kouankan s'il ya bien un sujet sur
lequel je connais pas assez pour en
parler c'est celui là
je suis vraiment très très très très
léger sur les crypto monnaie je connais
un tout petit peu le principe n'est pas
plus que ça j'ai pas spécialement
d'opinion
donc c'était une question du château
internet chat donc dopage le gars est
revenue revenons à nos moutons parce que
là dessus j'ai trois banalités quoi ça
m'intéresse qu'on réfléchisse au fait
que la monnaie soit émise par autre
chose que la banque centrale
j'ai aucune idée des formes de
régulation dont il a besoin je connais
pas assez le sujet pour avoir un avis
intelligent
je sais à peine commence à marquer
techniquement bonne réponse le bloc 107
parle oui je vois vaguement comment ça
marche pas plus
déployer un réseau non filaire ça c'est
un sujet que je connais mieux tu sais
tirer des câbles c'est ça dont un
certain steven je suis quand même
président d'une fédération de
fournisseurs d'accès à internet
associatif donc ouais j'ai une petite
idée de comment on fabrique du réseau
depuis les couches tout en bas jusqu'au
couches tout en haut et on vit des
blacks marché comme des black box chez
toi non comme on peut vérifier
en fait comment tu pourrais vérifier toi
c'est facile en fait tu adhères à
quelques-uns des fournisseurs d'accès
internet de la fédération tu deviens un
peu actif puis du coup tu fera partie de
l'équipe 2006 en esperant et les bonnes
compétences
et puis bah du coup c'est toi qui es
irak et les machines en baie et tu
constateras dans la bei a que nos
machines ont fait pour attirer chez toi
c ou c commencé quand je sais combien
alors c'est très variable parce qu'il ya
trente associations
fdn point org ça te donne le site web de
la fédé dessus tu trouves la liste des
trente associations membres tu peux
aller voir sur les sites web de chacune
des associations en fonction de la
région des affinités né et c'est
le plomb le plan national sur le
numérique le grand plan pour les tirer
de la fibre soudain plan national très
haut débit quel beau sujet qu'est ce que
tu veux que je te raconte tout où on n'a
pas le temps dont on n'a pas le temps
croustillons et on commence par le
croustillant le croustillant comme on
aime c'est à dire source est étayée
trianguler on t'écoute
croustillant
alors je te donne du source et puis
après tu en tires ce que tu veux la
commission européenne a mis près de deux
ans a validé le plan
parce qu'en fait la puissance publique
l'état mais pas que injecte de l'argent
dans le déploiement des réseaux et au
final c'est toujours des opérateurs
privés qui déplorent les réseaux et donc
il fallait convaincre la commission
européenne que c'était pas du
financement déguisés pour orange et
compagnie et le gouvernement a mis deux
bonnes années à réussir à en convaincre
la commission et il ya des raisons à ça
c'est que c'est du financement déguisé
d'orange
ça a été source et cannes ou non mais la
pratique de le montre en fait moi j'ai
compris ça quand je lisais l'appel à
projet avant même que ça ça commence
l'idée c'est que dans toutes les régions
en fait ils ont découpé la france en
trois zones tu as les zones très denses
paris-lyon-marseille ce genre de ce
genre de coin
sur lesquels ça va être le bordel tu as
les zones denses autour sur lesquels les
opérateurs se sont mis d'accord entre
eux pour co-investir dire que 1 2 3 4
opérateurs se sont alliés pour dire dans
telle zone on va fibre est typiquement
la banlieue parisienne est couverte à
90% comme ça
et puis il ya tout le reste ou en fait
les opérateurs sont pas d'avis il allait
investir parce qu'ils estiment que c'est
pas rentable de le faire pour eux
service public il est où à bas le
service public orange fait pas son
boulot orange c'est une boîte privée
camarades
et donc dans ces zones là la puissance
publique va investir le montage est
assez curieux parce que dans toutes les
zones où les opérateurs ont jugé que
c'était rentable et et vont investir
tout seuls comme des grands la puissance
publique s'interdit d'investir
cirque en fait l'état décide que il va
investir du pognon partout il est
certain qu pas en gagner et il va pas en
investir là où il pourrait en gagner
pour compenser ces autrefois on faisait
ça du temps où les télécoms c'était un
service public
on investissait dans tout le pays et
puis dans les zones très rentable ça
crachait du blé dans les zones pas
rentable ça on perdait et l'un dans
l'autre ça faisait une somme nulle on
appelait ça la péréquation
ça ne se pratique plus ça c'est du
langage anciens des années 70
et donc le l'approché celle-là dont il
ya eu d une description du projet type
sur comment on vit comment on fibre la
rase campagne si tu veux et puis chaque
collectivité territoriale doit monter
son projet choisir un peu le montage
légale qui va bien derrière faire un
appel d'offres auprès des opérateurs
qu'ils savent faire ça et puis on va
voir à qui on délègue aux services
publics et dans le montage de ce
financement là
il ya écrit en filigrane tout du long le
but est de financer orange
c'est ton interprétation oui c'est mon
interprétation
il n'empêche que la pratique depuis cinq
ans montre que mon interprétation est la
bonne une question d'internet une
parenthèse c'est queen black box
c'est quoi une black box ça c'est en
fait c'est une référence à ce qu'on a
appelé les boîtes noires
dans le projet de loi sur le
renseignement
en fait c'est un truc dont on n'a
toujours pas la définition exacte on n'a
que sa définition légale qui serait
interceptions en direct sur le réseau
des opérateurs d'un certain nombre de
données mais on sait pas bien lesquels
et même la définition légale est
relativement floue et on n'a toujours
pas vu deux décrets d'application de ce
truc là paraître et il y en a toujours
pas d'installer officiellement ses
propres l'intérêt de ce genre de
dispositif
l'intérêt de la loi enseignement impro
terrorisme par rapport au terrorisme à
peu près nuls et surtout coup en fait tu
as deux ans pourtant nous a dit il ya
deux jours que vous ne comprenez pas
qu'on puisse passer des lois de type
état d'urgence alors qu'il ya des
attentats dans la rue ouais ça c'est de
la logique shadok ça marche super bien
en fait s'il n'ya pas d'attentats les
politiques explique que c'est grâce à
l'état d'urgence donc il faut le
maintenir s'il ya des attentats les
politiques explique que c'est parce
qu'il ya pas assez l'état d'urgence il
faut le renforcer
donc en fait ils démontrent jamais rien
il démontre jamais que c'est utile il
affirme que c'est utile et que ça marche
et puis si jamais ça marche pas il faut
le renforcer ça ça relève de la croyance
c'est exactement de la logique qui seul
un shadok
si tout va bien c'est parce qu'on pompe
si ça échoue c'est parce qu'on comptait
pas assez fort et qu'il faut pomper plus
c'est donc dans le doute on continue à
pompe et
tu verrais des choses que mon pour
arranger les choses
il ya des questions que je vois pas
traitées par les politiques et qui
pourtant me paraissent intéressantes
pourquoi quelqu'un qui a grandi en
france a envie d'aller tirer dans la
foule et de mourir abattu par la police
pourquoi c'est intéressant je trouve
comme question je te rappelle que la
réponse de d'un précédent premier
ministre qui est en train de se débattre
dans l'essonne pour savoir s'il est élu
était que chercher à comprendre s'est
déjà excusé
c'est manuel valls
et pourtant c'est fondamental comprendre
ça c'est vachement intéressant et je
vois pas le politique travailler
là-dessus comprendre pourquoi comprendre
comment se construisent ces réseaux
typiquement la loi renseignement elle
permet de grande nature de choses
allaient permettre la surveillance
ciblée
ce qui est pas forcément malsain en soit
géré que quand il ya une suspicion
légitime contre quelqu'un d'appartenir à
la pègre de faire du blanchiment
d'argent de préparer du terrorisme je re
division fiscale l'évasion fiscale
facture des trucs un peu un peu pas bien
quoi
que les services de renseignement aient
les moyens de mettre légalement sous
surveillance sur écoute d'aller poser
des micros en fait toutes les
barbouzeries qu'ils font depuis toujours
qui est un cadre légal dessus moi je
trouve que c'est plutôt cool quoi c'est
plutôt bien et puis dans le dans la
loire enseignement il y a si tu regardes
bien les critères pour faire ça ils sont
très floues et souvent ils correspondent
pas forcément avec l'intérêt général
correspondant les deux courts
bas typiquement quand on te dit défendre
l'intérêt des acteurs économiques
importants pour la nation
ça c'est dans l'essai dans les textes
je suis pas tout à fait certain que
défendre le
les intérêts d'un actionnaire privé ce
soit l'intérêt général de la france tu
vois oui mais par exemple si je te
promets des diables une start up
française oui
qui découvre le saint graal
cette entreprise est menacée d'un x ou y
services étrangers en termes de
renseignements économiques
ça peut peut-être avoir quand même un
intérêt d'avoir un dispositif qui puisse
surveiller ceux qui surveillent notre
boîte bah oui et non oui ça a un intérêt
je pense que c'est plus efficace de
former les start up
à la protection de leurs de licques bas
un peu d'éducation informatique s'est
pas c'est pas plus mal un peu d'hygiène
en matière de sécurité informatique ça
fait toujours du bien
ça c'est par exemple boulot de landecy
c'est pas du tout les services de
renseignement
et surtout quand tu regardes la
définition légale jeux les plus en tête
au mot près
mais on explique que c'est en gros les
les entreprises qui ont une importance
vitale pour la nation donc c'est pas les
start up c'est orange c'est alès c'est
tout un total elf aquitaine
ce genre de start-up la coi qui peuvent
aider en afrique tout en haut qui
peuvent aider dans plein de choses qui
fournissent des postes pour les
ministres en fin de carrière qui alors
question d'internet il ya le bac il ya
t'il des black box de la dgse dans tout
l'est des slam de france non non donc le
savoir
en fait si tu as des moyens de le savoir
parce que les les équipements sont quand
même relativement maîtrisée par les
ingénieurs et globalement
pour installer ça il aurait fallu en
installer des dizaines de milliers
ce qui veut dire qu'il y aurait des
milliers d'ingénieurs télécom qui
bossent dessus et qui savent ce qui
tourne sur leur équipement et que dans
tout l'orient n'est pas un qui soit venu
me parler avec une bière juste j'y crois
pas si tu veux du grand complot ça
marche super bien quand il ya 30
personnes pas qu'on tient à 4000 oui ici
je te dis que le projet manhattan était
noyauté avec trois cent mille personnes
ben ils n'étaient pas si secret que ça
et surtout les toutes les personnes
concernées étaient toutes au même
endroit
à revoir à discuter bon tu me prends à
des fous là mais bon question d'internet
c'est possible de préserver sa vie
privée sur internet quand on n'a pas de
connaissances techniques pour utiliser
les outils préconisés entre guillemets
vpn proxy etc non non non mais même avec
les outils c'est pas possible
clermont ensuite compliqué non mais même
avec les outils c'est pas possible il ya
des choses qui n'ont pas de sens
je te donne deux exemples très bête tu
veux utiliser un site de rencontres pour
draguer bon un show qu'importe
si surtout profil tu mets ton vrai âge
et une photo de toi et ton vrai prénom
tepa a tellement anonyme quoi
à part le nom de ton patron il manque
pas grand chose
bon
et je te parle d'un service relativement
accessoires mais déjà t'es pas tellement
anonyme est en fait si sur ton profil tu
m'épates à photo tu perds 90% des
contacts potentiels
bon parce que les gens savent pas à qui
il parle puisqu'il relativement logique
on appris ta faute ou mais ça marche
bien m'a pris ta faute aux pourparlers
sur le tchat bah oui du coup quand tu
arrives au rancart or on n'est jamais
déçu un mec que tu draguer il est déçu
bon athées comme il continue
typiquement tu décides que tu veux être
un peu protégés mais tu utilise twitter
oui mais toutes les données 4 8 heures
il les a quand même c'est ton compte sur
lequel tu as twitté telle et telle chose
talk est telle et telle chose tu as
passé tant de temps à regarder telle pub
et ils le savent toutes ces infos la
même si tu passes par des proxy et les
machins ils ont
en fait tu peut pas protéger ta vie
privée
et c'est pas forcément souhaitable de le
faire
la vraie question les dual c'est d'abord
quelles informations ils collectent à
ton insu ça c'est très embêtant sert
typiquement le petit like facebook que
tu vois en bas de tous les articles de
blogs de tous les articles de presse et
c'est lui permet à facebook même si tu
n'as pas de comptes chez eux de savoir
ce que tu as vu quand à quelle heure tu
sais tu sais ce que tu vas voir après ce
que tu verras après et du coup de faire
du profit et du profiling de regarder à
il a regardé un article sur s'appuie un
art ic sur ça donc du coup c'est
probablement un mec blanc dans la
trentaine instruit avec tel niveau de
revenu ils savent ce profil est très
très vite à partir de tes lectures même
s'ils n'ont pas ta page facebook
derrière donc même avec une navigation
privée j'y crois un qui croit vraiment
de l'authentification par habitude oui
bien sûr ça que je parle bien sûr mais
ils n'ont pas besoin de titre de dette
identifier exactement parce qu'ils s'en
foutent ils veulent pas avoir ton nom
ton prénom ton adresse ils sont ils s'en
cogne de ça il voit à peu près à quelle
catégorie socioprofessionnelle
t'appartient dû coûter encore un peu
jeune pour qu'on me propose les couches
seniors 1 tu es un peu vieux pour qu'on
te propose
les bouquins pour réviser le bac du coup
il cible très vite en termes de
marketing
il voit bien si tu es plutôt dans les
très pauvres
au rsa et a galéré en fin de mois ou six
étaient plutôt du genre à te dire que ça
fait trois ans que t'as pas changé de bm
efforts étant le ch est une autre
pourquoi j'ai des qg cul des pubs de
louboutin sur
sa demande toi ce qui colle à sa dans
ses habitudes peut-être pour se changer
de tes tongs non parce que vous voyez
pas les images vous autres derrière
internet mais le mec il est en tongs et
des tongs avec
tu vois pas bien ce que pense benjamin
bayart de l'action de l'ansea
plutôt pas mal en général quand il
publie des guides d'hygiène informatique
ils sont plutôt bons quand ils font des
préconisations en matière de sécurité
elles sont plutôt bonnes
où tout part en découlent poupart j'en
sais rien moi je n'ai jamais croisé non
non tu veux quand je fais table ouverte
qui vient pas picoler donc il n'est
jamais croisé pour invite tous les
invite
sédhiou ne s'appelle ni moi en général
quand je fais table ouverte c'est pas
souvent ces temps-ci mais quand je le
fais je l' annonce sur twitter
s'il me suis sur twitter il sera donc au
courant comme tout le monde et
comme tous mes followers mais pas
follower il a le droit de venir s'il
faisait toujours ça se passe toujours à
quand ça se passe c'est au push la
distrib en ardent le deuxième en général
le jeudi soir en général c'est le jeudi
soir mais ça fait presque un an qui en a
pas eu
on en était l'état d'urgence
sinon est-ce que c'est bien à landecy
oui typiquement quand ils font du
conseil au gouvernement ils font ça bien
qu'en gouvernement a des velléités de
[__] la merde dans le chiffrement
landecy rappelle de manière assez forte
que non le le chiffrement de bout en
bout est une nécessité impérieuse en
matière de sécurité pour les gens et
pour les autres il pour les entreprises
mais pour les gens parce que si tu veux
moi je suis plus attaché à la liberté
des gens qu liberté des entreprises
parce qu'en fait c'est les droits de
l'homme qu'on a proclamé en 1789 pas les
droits de l'investisseur et je trouve ça
assez important l'arabie saoudite l'inde
s'y fait du bon boulot là dessus le
gouvernement suit pas si tu veux quand
les camps la note de trois ou quatre
pages qui a écrit 26 fuites dans la
presse c'est parce que le gouvernement
ne suis pas je sais pas d'où vient la
fuite est ce qu'elle vient de quelqu'un
dans les conseillers gouvernementaux est
ce qu'elle vient de quelqu'un à nancy
mais quelqu'un s'est rendu compte que
c'était une grosse connerie tu pas les
écouter et a fait fuiter mais la note
elle était de très bonne qualité cirque
le gouvernement reçoit les bons conseils
depuis la bonne instance cette instance
fonctionne et s'ils n'appliquent pas
c'est quoi cette forfaiture
ils reçoivent des instructions d'autre
part
j'en sais rien je n'en sais rien est ce
qu'ils reçoivent des instructions
d'autre part j'en suis même pas sûr je
pense qu'ils sont juste con
revenu c'est difficile de se concentrer
avec toi une question d'internet
pourquoi se méfier de la loi
renseignement quels sont les risques à
venir
à venir ils sont pas à venir en fait
ils sont pas à venir du tout ils sont
réels ils sont en ce moment
il ya une volonté très forte de tous les
gouvernements occidentaux de surveiller
leurs populations c'est compréhensible
comment expliquer ça facilement
internet est le signe du fait que le
monde est en train de changer
souvent en conférence je raconte ça je
raconte longuement pendant une à deux
heures de conférence ce qu'internet
change dans la société le fait que le
fait d'avoir un réseau de
télécommunication électronique
met à plat les rapports sociaux permet
aux gens de s'exprimer ce qui ne pouvait
pas faire avant géré t'aurais pas pu
tenir une chaîne de télé avant at chaîne
de télé battu tient une chaîne youtube
sur laquelle tu interviews des gens tu
pouvais pas ne pas
vous laisser faire
tu faisais de la radio parce que c'était
de la radio pirate
ça c'était pas possible avant internet
et ça en fait ça change des structures
de la société et
quand tu présentes ça quand je présente
ça en conférence en fait à l'idée
internet change le monde et ça c'est une
idée fausse parce que c'est une idée à
laquelle tu imagines une société elle
est là puis elle va bien fait sa vie
tranquille où elle est sortie du 19e
siècle l'un vante la télé la radio tout
sa belle société complète et tout et
puis on pose un internet dessus et puis
ça là des formes est ça la change mais
c'est qui le de l'extérieur qui pose
internet sur le monde pour le changer
soit tu acceptes l'hypothèse divine moi
j'aime bien doux et on dit que internet
un outil envoyé par dieu aux hommes pour
les rendre meilleurs moi je veux bien
l'hypothèse divine je la trouve cool ou
bien tu acceptes pas cette hypothèse là
et tu dis que c'est pas extérieur et que
donc internet est l'outil dont nos
sociétés se sont dotés pour pouvoir
changer
et en fait quand une société change il
ya un risque que les puissants ne soient
plus les mêmes
et donc les puissants d'avant ou envie
de le rester et s'oppose aux changements
et ont peur du changement et ce genre de
crainte là ça se traduit toujours par le
fait que les puissants ont peur du
peuple parce que ils ne comprennent pas
et qu'ils ont peur de perdre le pouvoir
fco pour les aider
bah il ya une des solutions
traditionnelles en france qui est de les
décapiter
le freedom razer comme ils disent juste
là je suis pas spécialement fan
je suis pas spécialement fan parce que
ça se termine pas très bien enfin c'est
le truc pas cool
mais en fait tu as deux tas de façons de
faire ça c'est soit le changement se
fait en douceur cercle monde se
réforment échanges sans forcément finir
en guerre civile sans forcément finir
dans un bain de sang juste le monde
change et donc les structures de pouvoir
s'ouvrir typiquement tout le boulot qui
a été fait par etalab je le trouve
intéressant il est faible en ce sens
qu'il et inabouti explique et à l'aube
pour tout ce qui est la notion d' open
data d' open government de mise à
disposition de plein de données
publiques français et/ou en fait le
si tu veux la puissance publique accepte
de dévoiler ce qu'elle fait et donc les
gens ont le droit de regarder ont le
droit d'en faire des choses des choses
bêtes des choses intelligentes et de
travailler sur de la données publiques
et ça ça permet plein de choses c'est
une forme de transparence ou l'état dit
publiquement ce qu'il fait
ça c'est plutôt bien et henri verdier le
mec a fait ça il a fait ça plutôt bien
alors tu peux voir le voir la motié à
moitié vide et puis dire c'est très
inaboutie c'est encore insuffisant il
faudrait faire dix fois plus dix fois
mieux machin oui m'enfin c'est un très
bon mouvement dans le bon sens et c'est
plutôt bien oui si tu nous entends voilà
attends toujours très à coeur il en
revient et donc le
ça c'est plutôt du mou du mouvement de
la société se réforme et du coup elle va
changer sans casser et puis tu as des
tas de rigidité
est typiquement la loi renseignements
elles elles relèvent des rigidités les
velléités de d'empêcher le chiffrement
des communications sa relève des
rigidités de l'incapacité à comprendre
mais de même si tu veux que l'amendement
de françois fillon en 1996 sur le paquet
télécom qui disait que pour ouvrir un
site web bah oui un site web qui
comprend c'est de l'image c'est du texte
c'est du son on image texte sont tous
assez audiovisuel et donc pour ouvrir un
site web il faut demander une
autorisation d'émettre au csa ça c'était
l'esprit de l'amendement fillon en 96
c'est une rigidité c'est une peur
tout le monde se fout de ce truc là elle
le trouve totalement ridicule
aujourd'hui tous les gens qui
connaissaient un petit peu internet en
96-97 trouvé ça parfaitement ridicule
juste on était 0,2 pour cent de la
population et on a eu un mal de chien à
lutter contre cet amendement
aujourd'hui on aurait moins de mal il
paraît très ridicule à tellement de gens
que ça ferait ça ferait rire tout le
monde
la loi renseignements c'est le même
problème en fait c'est un problème très
similaire tu contrôles argumentaire que
qu'il ya en face
d'eux on est obligé de pomper pour
arrêter le chat d'oc
oui qu'est-ce que tu répond qu'est-ce
que tu réponds à quelqu'un qui a perdu
un enfant proches dans un attentat
si un jour on dit voilà c'est de votre
faute on aurait pu choper tous les
terroristes d'un coup valence et en fait
on n'aurait pas pu en fait on n'aurait
pas pu c'est ça le problème à cause du
degré de technologie qui utilise non ça
c'est un argument technique or c'est pas
un argument technique c'est pas un
problème de technique
on n'aurait pas pu parce que si tu
prends prend les choses très simples
quasiment tous les terroristes qui ont
agi ces derniers temps étaient fichés
ils étaient fichés cirque on savait très
bien qu'il y avait un problème avec eux
pourquoi il n'était pas surveillée
pourquoi on n'a pas vu pas de moyens
parce qu'en fait pour surveiller
quelqu'un à plein temps il faut je sais
plus 20 ou 25 fonctionnaires de police
qu'à une soixantaine sur qui il faut un
budget de malade mental je passe tu vois
30 personnes c'est énorme comme but de
remplacer sa part l'intelligence
artificielle allemand on peut pas est ce
que le bigger jeu ont rebondi question
internet est ce que le big data est une
nouveauté bénéfiques ou est-ce que c'est
trop dangereux pour qu'on lui fasse
confiance quid de l' influence de le
futur intelligence artificielle dans ma
vie privée est donc dans le
renseignement il ya trop de bullshit
world dans le dans la question pour que
je puisse apporter une réponse
intelligente bon alors je reformule
est ce que le big data ça peut servir à
quelque chose ou est ce que c'est trop
dangereux alors en fait big data ça veut
rien dire donc on va rejouer je
commençais par des bunkers ce mot-là ego
big data ça veut dire grosse masse de
données est ce que les grosses masses de
données permettant de faire des calculs
statistiques c'est quelque chose d'utile
tous les chercheurs en sociologie te
diront que oui c'est l'évidence même
après ce qu'on appelle big data c'est à
dire le fait que des entreprises
utilisent des grosses masses de données
pour faire ce qui sert leurs intérêts à
elle ça peut faire quelque chose d'utile
bah oui pour les entreprises en question
mais pas pour toi
je prends un exemple que j'aime beaucoup
celle usage du big data par les
compagnies d'assurance le principe même
la définition de l'assurance et de
mutualiser le risque c'est de dire ok on
te couvre contre l'infarctus du myocarde
et donc bah on couvre toute la
population contre ce risque là et en
fait il ya en moyenne x personne sur un
million qui ont un infarctus dans
l'année et donc qu'ils vont coûter cher
à soigner mais comme on est 66 millions
en france bah ça fera que tant chacun a
payé 2 d'assurance maladie qu'on appelle
sécurité sociale et du coup le risque
est très facile à mutualiser bien plus
socialiste ou anarchistes offre un
subtil mélange des deux avec d'autres
choses une espèce d'anarcho libéral
d'extrême gauche ça c'est très compliqué
donc le principe de l'assurance et
mutualisés or si tu regardes ce que
cherche à faire les compagnies
d'assurance avec toutes les données
statistiques qu'elles peuvent collecter
sur toi c'est établir son profil de
risque pour assurer en payant très très
peu cher d'assurance les gens qui
présentent très peu de risques et puis
faire payer très cher aux autres c'est à
dire en fait ne plus mutualisés c'est
normal mais non c'est juste idiot c'est
totalement idiot parce qu'en fait ça
veut dire que tu mutualisent plus le
risque et si tu veux pas mutualiser le
risque et ben tu t'assures pas c'est
vachement simple en fait puisque si
vraiment a aucun risque toi tu présente
un profil mettons absolument idéal sur
tel jeu d'assurance mais même si on te
propose un contrat à deux euros par mois
ces deux euros trop cher puisqu'il ya
pas de risque tu vas pas payer deux
euros pour couvrir un risque nul c'est
débile
en fait ça n'est intelligent que si on
part du principe que c'est mutualisé
qu'on couvre pour tout le monde et que
ces 3 euros 50 pour tout le monde et là
ça a du sens là ça a du sens
effectivement toi tu présentes très très
très très peu de risques si jamais par
extraordinaire ça t'arrive est battu
seraient couverts ça n'arrivera
probablement pas mais a payé trois euros
pour rien mais toute façon ça permet de
couvrir tous les autres donc bah t'as
plutôt créer une société plus douce est
meilleur qu'il était un peu égalitaires
un peu pas mal où on les gens qu'on pas
de bol c'est plutôt bien mais ce que
font les compagnies d'assurance en
faisant ça c'est qu'elles sont en train
de se rendre inutiles
elles sont en train de tuer la vache ou
le veau d'or elles sont en train de tuer
la poule aux oeufs d'or c'est parce que
c'est une vision court termiste oui
c'est surtout parce que c'est une vision
parfaitement idiote de leur métier
qu'est ce que tu penses du film
bienvenue à gattaca parce que tu l'as vu
je le trouve plutôt optimiste en fait
je le trouve plutôt optimiste il
présente une vision dystopique
assez sombre je pense que la réalité
pourrait être bien pire que ça
question de l'internet de la communauté
de points c'est quoi la neutralité du
net points d'interrogations pourquoi
faut-il à défendre point d'interrogation
quid de l'influencé futur de
l'intelligence artificielle dans la vie
privée alors pareil là il ya un bol site
web qu'il faut que je flingue
intelligence artificielle
je sais que c'est le terme approprié
c'est un terme que j'accepte d'utiliser
quand je discute avec des informaticiens
parce qu on est entre gens du métier moi
j'ai étudié ça quand j'étais à l'école
l'un de mes sujets de spécialisation
c'était les réseaux de neurones en
particulier les cartes de cohen pour les
gens que ça intéresse
dans la discussion en vrais français de
tous les jours
je refuse d'utiliser ce mot là parce que
c'est un mot qui portent plein de pleins
d'à priori dans la tête des gens en
particulier ça suppose qu'on va rendre
une machine intelligente ce qui n'est
pas le cas
aucun algorithme à aucun moment n'est
dotée ni de volonté ni le sentiment il
n'est donc pas intelligent de conscience
il n'est pas noté de conscience plutôt
content de donner des droits aux bouts
et ben en fait parce que on suppose le
mot intelligence artificielle au sens
réel du mot intelligence et donc si on
parle d'intelligence artificielle
le jour où on en trouvera une ne s'est
pas fait ça
alors il faudra réfléchir à quelles sont
ses droits quels sont ses devoirs et à
quel point est-ce que c'est un citoyen
mais il se trouve que pour le moment
tout ce qu'on fabrique c'est pas ça du
tout ce qu on te vend sous le nom
intelligence artificielle c'est juste un
petit peu d'analysé statistique est un
petit peu d'analysé structurelle et
prédictifs bah oui les statistiques
c'est prédictifs
j'ai ainsi je te lance une balle tu va
la rattraper ses prédictif parce que
statistiquement
99.999 neuf fois sur cent quand la balle
suis telle trajectoire allait arrive à
tel endroit et puis tu la rattrape il se
trouve qu'une fois de temps en temps
elle est déviée par quelque chose auquel
tu as pas fait gaffe et du coup tu la
rate
mais ça c'est de l'analyse statistique
et prédictive ça peut même être de
l'analyse structurelle parce qu'il se
trouve que tu calcules super bien de
tête que tu as donc su évaluer la force
et l'impulsion et les mouvements que
j'ai donné à la baguette a fait du
calcul de trajectoire tu sais que c'est
une parabole et du coup tu pourrais tu
places la main au bon endroit pour
rattraper les deux sorties de gravité
ces couvre déjà
9 81 paris
donc ça c'est les deux formes
d'intelligence coup l artificiel qu'on a
de soi disant intelligence artificielle
qui sont soit de l'analyse structurelle
soit de l'analyse statistique à partir
de laquelle on fait des prédictions
c'est en moyenne les gens qui ont
regardé telle et telle est l article du
catalogue amazon ont acheté tel truc est
donc à la zone il fait des stats et ici
il fait ok tu as cherché le tome 1 le
tome 2 est le tome 3 d'harry potter je
vais proposer le top 4 tu parles d'un
bon résultat statistique quand même
c'est pas con mais voilà c'est ça ce
qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle et prédictive c'est de cet
ordre là il se trouve que l'analyse
statistique régulièrement fait ressortir
des choses
hyper surprenante est que toi tu es
incapable de lire à l'oeil nu
l'exemple relativement classique c'est
on analyse tout ce que tu achètes quand
tu fais tes courses mais dont tu as ta
carte de fidélité de la supérette en bas
de chez toi puis tu fais des courses
régulièrement
on va être capable à partir de ça de
dire plein de trucs que toi tu ne sais
pas sur ta vie privée
parce que ben on a des modèles
prédictifs là dessus
typiquement quand t'as pas le moral t'as
plus tendance à acheter tel trop tel
produit plutôt que tel autre et du coup
on arrive à dire que tu es déprimé si ça
se trouve tu t'es même pas rendu compte
consciemment que tu étais dans une
petite phase de dépression mais juste
l'analyste statistiques le montrent
on arrive à détecter si tu es malade on
arrive à détecter quand les femmes sont
enceintes parce qu'il ya tel ou tel
comportement dans les achats qui change
ou quand tout va se séparer ou quand on
va se séparer c'est ça c'est de
l'analyse statistique prédictive et
c'est très surprenant parce qu'en fait
ça c'est des choses sur toi dompter même
pas forcément encore conscients ou que
tu avais pas accepter de dire que tu
dois pas encore émis l'hypothèse de
faire oui
un peu ce problème ça pas forcément ça
dépend de ce qu'on en fait et ça dépend
qui en fait quoi exemple imagine toi est
un fils ce fils veut devenir juge
dans son comportement sur internet on
décèle on détecte rapidement qui va
devenir juge ou journalistes ou quelque
chose ou d'un pouvoir qui est un peu
plus dur qu'un aujourd'hui si on
l'identifient comme personne à risque
pour le pouvoir dès le départ ça peut
poser un problème
est ce que je me suis bien fait
comprendre oui
oui ça peut poser un problème parce que
tu supposes en fait la tête est
exactement dans le modèle qui est prévu
par minority report qui est celui qui
raconte minority report est en fait tu
dois pas pouvoir reprocher aux gens une
analyse statistique tu dois pouvoir
reprocher aux gens ce qu'ils ont fait
bien typiquement mettons tu te sépares
d' avec ta copine
copains bourrés au dernier à vos
dernières nouvelles je te croyais hétéro
donc tu te sépares d' avec ta copine
il se trouve que c'est plutôt
mouvementée que ça se passe pas bien que
vous engueuler vraiment beaucoup
statistiquement en fait il ya un risque
que ça dégénère vraiment
au crime passionnel en crime passionnel
ya un risque mais en fait tant que t'as
pas céder à la pulsion c'est pas un
crime passionnel n'y a pas de crime
passionnel si tu contrôles tabulation
et puis que au final où que l contrôler
ses pulsions et qu'elle te plante pas le
couteau qu'elle a dans la main et que à
la place la plante le couteau dans la
table et puis elle prend son sac et s
bar il n'y a pas de crime passionnel est
en fait tant que ça n'a pas eu lieu tu
peux pas savoir les statistiques disent
la probabilité de crime passionnel viens
viens de passer pendant ce moment là de
0,00 0 01 % à 35 % c'est colossal mais
ça n'a pas eu lieu et quand bien même ça
aurait atteint 99,9 pour cent tant que
ça n'a pas eu lieu
il n'y a pas de faits reprochés
ça peut justifier que les voisins s'en
mêle pas ce que vous criez ça devient
dangereux on appelle la police la police
vient elle calme tout le monde c'est
relativement classique mais il ya pas
motif à l'incarcération ya pas d il ya
pas crime et ça c'est un problème de
fond dans le droit tu ne peux pas
condamner les gens pour des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas encore fait c'est
l'évidence même tous les juges le savent
l'intention peut être un crime la
préparation peut être un crime
typiquement préparer un acte de
terrorisme même si on ne le réalise pas
est en soi un crime mais tu vas pas du
tout en prison avec le même quota que si
tu as réellement
réalisé un acte terroriste c'est pas la
même peine on pourrait parler des heures
avec toi
question d'internet on peut ton corps
décentralisée internet pour nos
interrogations
ah ça c'est une grande question parce
qu'en fait c'est une question qui est
pleine de tristesse
peut-on être encore heureux dans le
monde moderne j'espère bien sinon faut
se pendre
peut-on encore créer une société un peu
justes malgré tu mets tout ce que tu
veux derrière le gouvernement le grand
capital les méchants j'espère bien si
l'on peut se pendre donc oui j'espère
qu'on peut encore décentralisée internet
la technologie le permet donc on peut
encore fabriquer des boues d'internet
neutre propre décentralisée qu'on a peur
nous mêmes autre question d'internet sa
bataille en sous marin pour annuler loi
où poussent inconstitutionnelle point
d'interrogation pays sous marins ont
fait pas de sonars anneaux ne m'en fais
pas de sous-marin du tout on publiera au
frontal ce qu'on fait dans les exégètes
amateurs on publie tout alors en fait on
est complètement sous marin avant sert
quand on quand on décide qu'on va
attaquer tel ou tel décret quand on
décide qu'on va lancer une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité sur
tel sujet tant que mémoire n'est pas
déposée au greffe du conseil d'état ou
au greffe du conseil constitutionnel ou
quoi on ne publie rien et on ne dit rien
sur nos intentions vous chiffrez tout
contre vous non non non non non c'est ce
pardon une fiche s aucune idée rien à
vous donner j'ai pas demandé je m'en
fous tu vas pas demandé non
je crois pas mais voilà gère les indices
habituels qui sont les contrôles aux
aéroports etc etc me font penser que ta
peau de fiches sg pas de fiche s mais
comment on fait pour demander alors en
fait la fiche est tu peux pas demander
entre répondra pas tu peux demander à
quelqu'un qui demande qu'on savoir tuba
ça c'est si tu as des copains dans ce
milieu là mais c'est pas mon cas
germa situer ce que j'ai le plus gradé
c'est quelqu'un dans ma famille qu'est
dans la police mais il aura passé info
là
puisqu'il les a j'ai pas envie d'une
demande et parce que j'en ai vraiment
rien à carrer
ce qu'on pouvait demander autrefois se
situe à une fiche renseignements
généraux
ça a tellement changé de nom c'est ainsi
que je sais même plus comment s'appelle
leurs fichiers mais là je suis certain
d'avoir une fiche rappelle d'edwige
ouais c'était quoi edwige un des
innombrables fichiers de police qui a
été retoquée par ce qu'il contenait trop
de choses sur trop de gens y avait des
chansons sur internet sur edvige alors
question d'internet benjamin bayart
peut-il développer sa thèse de la
dangerosité de la haine et saïda dg ceux
qui n'auraient le revel révèle pas les
failles qu'ils trouvent
alors ça pour le coup ça ça se rapproche
assez de la forfaiture
où vous qu'on affectionne beaucoup
parce que normalement le rôle de ces
agences là c'est d'améliorer la sécurité
des citoyens
quand on détecte une faille de sécurité
dans un logiciel
la question n'est pas de savoir si elle
sera exploitée mais est de savoir quand
elle sera exploitée et par qui elle sera
toujours exploités tiens si les gens de
la msa ont été assez malin pour la
trouver ils sont brillants ils sont
nombreux tout ce qu'on veut les méchants
ils sont pas bêtes ils sont un peu moins
nombreux mais quand même pas mal qu'il
est méchant en gros les plus lourdes et
des méchants en fait c'est une question
d'intention et c'est pas une question de
méthode quand tu cherches les failles
dans les systèmes informatiques
pour te marrer n'est pas dangereux pour
te [__] de la gueule des gens qu'on
voit un système tout trouvé mais pas
dangereux pour signaler les problèmes
n'étaient pas dangereux pour corriger
les problèmes n'étaient pas dangereux
quand tu cherches à mettre en danger les
gens pour leur extorquer du pognon
peut-être dangereux a été de faire ça tu
le sais bien on va arrêter avec toi
d'ailleurs il ne remplit pas
c'est bien je peux pas parler en public
oui ou de questions mais qui est donc en
fait pour moi ces gens là sont très
dangereux et nsa et des gse parce que
ils cherchent
voirie fabrique des failles ils ont plus
montrent certes ça leur arrive de
contribuer à des projets dont et de
exprès laisser traîner des failles de
dans
ces failles sont un danger public pour
tout le monde hier ce sera exploité par
des gens malveillants par des
malfaiteurs
c'est le sait le nid de tous les rangs
somewhere aujourd'hui
est en fait susciter ou le maintenir ces
dispositifs en fait affaiblir la qualité
la sécurité logicielle c'est mettre en
danger tout le monde et ils le font
pourquoi parce qu'ils espèrent comme ça
pouvoir s'introduire dans les systèmes
informatiques et pouvoir faire de
l'espionnage économique pouvoir faire
c'est comme ça qu'on va attraper les
terroristes et tout s'est jamais comme
ça pour les attrape jamais géré on les
attrape par de la surveillance policière
à l'ancien par le fait de les mettre sur
écoute de s'intéresser à ce qui fonde
regarder quel milieu il fréquente de
surveiller les trafics de pognon de
surveiller les trafics d'armes mais
évidemment contrôle quand on parle de
surveiller les trafics de bonnion ya
plus personne qu'il faut quand même bien
qu'on puisse faire transiter le pognon
tout le monde parle luxembourg et la
suisse si non comment veux tu qu'on
fasse du blanchiment proprement et mais
comment tu veux qu'on survivent en
travaillant oui ils travaillent pas ces
gens un siphon d'optimisation fiscale
non ça c'est leur avocat fiscaliste tu
as eu merci tu as confiance aux torts
raisonnablement
en fait moi j'ai confiance dans tous les
outils de chiffrement y compris les plus
faibles
la question n'est pas de savoir s'ils
sont incassables tata deux questions
fondamentales en matière de chiffrement
pour moi tu as que c'est suffisamment
solide dans la question n'est pas simple
manifestement les bons albums
chiffrement sont suffisamment solides
puisqu'ils font chier la nsa voilà on a
appris ça vient snowden
rsa à pgp et ça c'est a priori solides
les courbes elliptiques salaires
mathématiquement assez solide sur les
courbes elliptiques devant après après
sûr
s'il n'avait pas corrompu juppé ou non
ils ont fait des trous dans l'open ssl 1
mais pas dans le panneau pgp pas dans
les algues de chiffrement justement
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont obligés
d'implémenter de faire rentrer des trous
dans les softs des bugs
donc si le premier morceau qui est ce
que c'est infiniment inviolable et en
fait ça c'est pas une question
intéressante la question c'est est-ce
que ça augmente le prix moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que ça c'est que ça
augmente le prix c'est un tel choix ou
bien tu as une petite fraction de la
population qui chiffrent une petite
fraction de ces communications qui sont
des communications hypersensible et en
fait d'abord ça flag les communications
ça dit ceci est hypersensible et donc
tout d'un coup ça devient hyper
surveiller et puis là si on cherche on
finira bien par trouver comment le
casser ou bien on décide de chiffres et
éventuellement de manière assez faibles
tout et ça c'est vachement intéressant
parce que ça augmente le prix de la
surveillance parce que au lieu d'écouter
un truc en clair on se met à devoir
écouter quelque chose qui est un peu
chiant à déchiffrer il n'y a pas besoin
de ce soir beaucoup il sut fait pas le
jeu des terroristes
non je fais le jeu qui consiste à
protéger la vie privée des gens et ça si
tu veux je te raconte pourquoi c'est
important oui en fait tu peux retrouver
ça j'aime bien le définir ou bien en
droit ou bien en philo tu préfères quoi
la fille louent ensuite le droit
en philo et bien en fait tu ne peux pas
développer
une pensée autonome si tu te crois
surveiller
quand tu te pense légitimement
surveiller tu développes une forme de
paranoïa
c'est pas que tout auto censure s'est
pas seulement ça c'est pas parce que je
vis sous le régime ben ali je ne
critiquerai pas le gouvernement je vais
même pas en parler à ma femme à mes
gosses à mon voisin j'en parle à
personne parce qu'il ya tellement de
gens qui coopèrent avec la police en
espérant grappiller un petit quelque
chose un bakchich un passe-droit un truc
il ya tellement de gens prêts à
collaborer avec la police et qui donc ça
va se retourner contre moi que je parle
à personne j'ai encore un peu d'idées
sur j'aime pas le gouvernement mais je
ne dis pas ça c'est l'autocensure mais
en fait quand tu te penses surveiller
quand tu te c'est surveillé il ya des
formes de pensée que tu ne développe
plus
c'est le principe de la pensée de meute
si tu vis tout le temps en groupe tout
le temps avec des gens qui te surveille
tu es incapable de
de formater de conceptualiser une idée
qui soit non cohérente avec le groupe et
donc quand tu te sens surveiller il ya
des formes de pensée que tu n'est plus
capable de développer et donc tu ne peux
pas avoir une pensée politique
dissidente dans un système de
surveillance massive sinon tout
nécessaire c'est nécessaire une pensée
dissidente en fait tu peux pas être en
accord avec le système si t'as pas le
droit d'être en désaccord
et si t'es pas capable de développer une
pensée qui soit hors de la norme établie
alors on est plus en démocratie parce
qu'en fait tu es plus un être libre et
donc la vie privée
c'est à dire le droit de développer une
pensée autonome
potentiellement en désaccord avec
la majorité bien pensants de la
population c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire parce que sinon ça veut dire
qu'il ya plus de pensée politique n'est
qu'une pensée de meute 11-10 l'esprit
critique oui on stérilise la pensée en
fait on empêche le développement de la
pensée c'est très joliment dit en droit
dans un arrêt de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme de 1978 dix classes
contre allemagne voilà tu chercheras
dans les mémoires des exégètes y laisse
été citée à plusieurs moments classe
contre allemagne 1978 on va être obligé
d'arrêter je te passe juste deux trois
petites questions à larache et je t
envoie directement sur la dernière
question que tu laisses à chaque fois
aux jeunes générations
et après parce que le magasin de bière
vin fermée pour un apéro donc j'ai les
failles windows à la défense qu'est ce
t'en penses c'est fait exprès c'est pas
fait exprès une connerie monumentale
c'est une connerie en termes de business
c'est une connerie en termes
d'indépendance technique c'est une
connerie en termes de maîtrise des
infrastructures de défense voilà c'est
juste une connerie je sais pas qui a
reims et qui là dedans mais c'est un
contrat passé avec un commercial voilà
pas les tirs ça te parle ouais pas
l'entière ça me parle outils de
surveillance massive la france espère
faire aussi bien elle devrait y arriver
non quand il s'agit de faire des trucs
crâne on est bon ok alors lorsque
l'utilisation du big data a pour but le
bien commun exemple l'optimisation du
métro londonien doit-on accepter le
partage de ces données perso ça les
persos hausse et répond à la question
basse et ça c'est pas les données persos
en fait
est-ce que sql profits compte un rôti
aux justifie le risque de perdre de
pertes de vie privée et d'exploitation
cible est mal tourné c'est très mal
tourner et je peux tu as peut apporter
la suite de la question précédente veut
en fait les deux les données que
j'aimais moi sur ma vie
m'appartiennent si j'avais une montre
connecter ce qui n'est pas mon cas et
que donc elle mesure en permanence mon
rythme cardiaque ma pression artérielle
mme machin tous à tous que c'est ma
température enfin tout ce que ça veut
tout ça génère des données sur moi et je
les envoie et je les stocke chez un
prestataire mais moi je considère que
ces données m'appartiennent est en fait
personne ne devrait y accéder pour faire
quoi que ce soit sans mon accord
et donc bah
j'en sais rien un organisme public de
recherche veut faire des études
statistiques sur la santé et donc
voudrait d'un côté accéder à mon dossier
médical pour savoir de quoi je suis
malade et de l'autre côté accéder à ces
mesures en continu pour pouvoir
alimenter son analyse pourquoi pas mais
il faut mon autorisation car il faut me
demander ces données doit pouvoir les
reprendre je dois pouvoir les amener
ailleurs je dois pouvoir exiger qu'elles
soient effacées en fait on doit
considérer qu'elles sont à moins avec
l'entreprise qui les hébergent les
héberge en monde et ne peut rien en
faire sans mon accord la même manière
facebook collecte des traces de toute ma
navigation pourquoi pas mais dans ce cas
là on doit à mon sens considérer que
facebook et mon prestataires et héberge
en mon nom mon historique de navigation
et que le don juan s'ils veulent le lire
pour faire du profit et du profilage
publicitaire il faut mon accord
s'ils veulent pouvoir le vendre à un
tiers il faut mon accord non pas de
principe mais à chaque fois qu'ils
veulent le vendre et je dois pouvoir
retirer cet accord et je dois pouvoir
récupérer ces données je dois pouvoir
les faire effacer tu nous expliques un
peu mastodonte
mastodonte alors pour ceux qui sont
encore sur twitter il est temps d'en
changer
c'est un réseau social qui ressemble un
peu à twitter
qui al'avantage d'être décentralisée
cirque il ya 2000 et des bananes
serveurs mastodonte différents
interconnectés entre eux ou les gens qui
ont un compte sur le serveur à peuvent
suivre les gens qui ont un compte sur le
serveur b
chaque admin a ses propres règles du jeu
sur ce qui est autorisé ce qui n'est pas
autorisé sur son serveur est ce qu'on a
le droit de poster du port nous pas est
ce qu'on a le droit de le poster en
public est ce qu'on doit le poster en
privé etc c'était il ya tout un tas de
petites règles le vrai intérêt que je
vois ça c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
puissance centrale il n'y a pas de
puissance centrale mastodonte c'est un
logiciel ça n'est que un logiciel le
réseau formé par ce logiciel s'appelle
le fait diverses
je trouve ça bien dans le concept c'est
comme le mail ça fonctionne sans
puissance centrale
mastodonte a commencé à vraiment percé
le soft est super récent il date du
début de l'année 2010 est il a commencé
à percer fin mars quand twitter a changé
encore un machin dans son mode de
fonctionnement que ça à couvrir non vous
inquiétez pas on y arrive on va venir
vous voir
il y a eu en quelques semaines en un
mois et demi un demi million
d'utilisateurs s'est passé de 20000
utilisateurs à 500 mille le nombre
d'instances de serveurs interconnectés
est passée de une dizaine un gros et 9
ou 10 tout petit à côté à presque 2000
maintenant
et ça s'est fait essentiellement pendant
le mois d'avril et le mois de mai c'est
en train de se calmer et en fait à
chaque fois que twitter fait une
connerie ça repart un changement de la
neutralité du net aux états unis
aura-t-il un impact en europe les
relations question la communauté oui
comment vis tu lis oui parce que ça va
ça va bouleverser les équilibres
économiques entre les ce qu'on appelle
les over the top les fournisseurs de
services ti google netflix et les
opérateurs réseaux ça va garantir la rue
la survie des plus gros et ça va
empêcher l'apparition des nouveaux alors
avant que tu laisses le conseil pour les
jeunes générations ont tenu au nom de
l'équipe a remercié toute la communauté
nous avoir suivis depuis 14h30 avec tous
ses directs on te laisse le mot de la
fin avec le conseil pour les jeunes
générations et dès que tu as fini au
couple y est et on conseille aux jeunes
générations qui roule à la cultiver vous
cultivez vous apprenez les choses le
plus possible éteignez la télé j'étais
là à rêver de l'ariège janvier
arrêtez les replays tout ça n'a aucun
intérêt le seul truc un peu rigolo ces
quelques séries regarder les parties
quelques documentaires sur arte way ou
ailleurs mais voilà jeté votre télé
cultivez vous apprenez militer 7 des
choses
restez pas enfermer chez vous il ya vous
avez toute la connaissance du monde à
portée de la main faites ce que vous
voulez girafe est fait
tache pas fait du pain comme comme mon
camarade à qui il manque une pâte
passionné vous pour n'importe quoi mais
passionné vous pour quelque chose
arrêtez de regarder la star ac et
hanouna à quoi fait un truc ce que vous
voulez mais un truc dont je vais vous
envoyer en remercie je t'en prie ou
coûte
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]